[Music]
Hello friends, once again we are here
with you in our program I like to know.
We are very excited for this new program
and we have very very interesting
questions today. Very exciting questions
and I have here with me uh my dear
pastor CA Murray and I am Daniel
Miranda. It's good to have you here
pastor. Good to be here.
And um before we begin, I would like to
remind you that you can send us your
questions to the following email
address. That's tvsumtv.org.
Again, tv.sumtv.org.
We promise that we will do our best to
give you an answer from the word of God
if there is an answer found in the word
of God.
So before we begin, pastor uh CA, could
you please lead us in prayer? My
pleasure to do so. Shall we pray?
Again, mighty father, we ask you to be
the teacher, the divine teacher, the
overarching teacher, the teacher from
which cometh all truth, all knowledge,
all wisdom. Amen. We ask Father that as
that as we go into your word that you
would give us the mind of Christ. Yes.
And a spiritual understanding of these
things. For who is sufficient for these
things to explain your word and yet your
word is written so that even a little
child can understand if his heart is
pure. So father be the teacher. We wait
upon you. May the words that we speak
not only be uh informative but may they
be edifying. May they be of spiritual
value to us who speak and to those who
hear what is said and we thank you in
Jesus name. Amen. Amen. Amen. Very good.
Okay, let's jump into our first question
and this one comes from Thomas Merose
and the question is hello. If the
investigative judgment began in 1844,
then why does 1 Peter 4:17 say that the
time has come that the judgment begins
at the house of God? The time of Peter
is way before 1844.
How do I reconcile this verse with what
we know to be true about 1844
and the beginning of the investigative
judgment?
I believe this is a great question. The
first time that I received this
question, I had to do some reading and
some praying to understand
uh or to know how exactly
answer this question. Pastor CA, any
thoughts on this? Uh yes, actually. Um
well, let's read the text. Um 1 Peter
4:17, for the time has come for judgment
to begin at the house of God. And if it
begins with us first, what will it what
will be the end of those who do not obey
the gospel of God? All right. The the
text is somewhat self-explanatory
in that the question may be asked, what
is the house of God? Well, in the next
line after the semicolon, uh, which was
added later, yes, wasn't in the
original. Um he says and if it begin
with us first. Yes. So the house of God
is us. The house of God are those who
name the name and claim the name of
Jesus Christ. He he is saying de facto
that judgment will begin with those who
claim to be Christians who claim the
name of Jesus Christ who take unto
themselves the name of Jesus. Now,
whenever you see an apparent or whenever
I see an apparent discrepancy or a
question,
usually the the the easiest path to take
is go into the Greek, see what's there,
and see how that bears upon uh uh the
particular text that you're wrestling
with. Uh that's why Greek is such a
wonderful language and it's so
wonderful. You know, I I I I can't say I
I I remember all my Greek classes, but I
do know how to use a Greek concordance
and I do know how to use a Greek
interlinear and they help so very very
much. So then what I came up with,
Daniel, is that when it says the time
has come, it is not talking about time
as we say, okay, it's time for us to
leave, which means right now.
Um the Greek word is kario. Yes, which
means more the season, the epic, the the
uh the occasion as opposed to the exact
time. So, this is not giving you a a
point in time like tomorrow, we're going
to go do this. It's saying the season
has come for judgment to begin at at the
house of God for those who claim the
name of Jesus Christ. Wow. Very, very
nice. Very interesting. Now I I also
understand it and correct me if I am
wrong
um in my Bible and I checked it in the
King James as well that the expression
has come
and and where it says it begins in the
verse they're idolized which means that
this is an addition to the text and it
doesn't that that specific phrase is not
in the original.
So it would read for the time for the
time for the judgment to begin at the
house of God. Mhm. Uh
so that makes me or or or in other words
the way I understand this verse is if if
I read before a few verses before he's
speaking about the the sufferings of the
Christians for God's glory that uh
they're persecuted that they're buffeted
that they suffer as murderers as it says
in verse 15. Mhm. Um so I understand
that contextually and I know we have
used this verse for for the investigated
judgment but I understand that
contextually here is referring to the
sufferings of the Christians. Yes. And
they are to suffer first and that's why
the ver the following verse in verse 18
it says and if the righteous is scarsely
saved. In other words, uh if if as being
righteous, we are saved through
suffering, what will be the what will
the ungodly and the sinner appear or
what will be the end of them? I mean, if
if we being righteous are suffering all
this, what will be the suffering and the
end of of of the wicked? Um but again,
um that expression as I understand it
has come um is an addition. So it does
not and as you explained it very well
from the Greek it does not refer to
specific time in in that moment when
Peter was writing but to a season. Yes.
That uh that will come. Season. Yeah.
You know it it's it's it that's why I
like when we come to this particular
program. It is one of my favorites
because for me um it was enough to find
out that time didn't mean exact time but
then you you put a little cherry on the
Sunday you know by adding the idea and
it is very true that has come is
atalicized so it's not in the original
so it has it has been added and it does
alter the meaning a little bit when you
when you put in those two words um uh
like some people say the Bible says be
ye perfect well it says be ye therefore
perfect and it doesn't translate exactly
the same as be perfect because the
therefore says that that statement is
based upon a number of things that went
before. So you just can't pull it out of
context and say be perfect. Well, this
adds another another layer. The time has
come is not in the original. It has been
it has been added. Uh and it does change
and it makes it actually a little bit
more difficult to to wrestle with by
adding those words. So it's a little
cleaner a little cleaner landing dare I
say without those words. and uh makes it
makes it uh much much smoother. So well
done uh pastor uh you you've added to my
knowledge here. I didn't even think of
that uh on that wise but uh we I think
we've built a case sequentially time
doesn't mean exact time and has come has
been added and it's not original and you
you will see this and and uh thank
goodness that when the the people add
things they atalicize them so you know
it's not in the original. So you can uh
wrestle with the Bible without this
additional weight of something added
that wasn't in the original manuscript.
Uh and it makes it much easier to to
wrestle with. Amen. Thank you, Pastor
CA. Well, our next question I think we
are going to spend uh a lot of time on
this one because we have five questions
uh in in one question and this one comes
from
Museni. I hope I am not uh slaughtering
the name Museni
and and it's worth reading the entire
question because it's very deep. I
really like this question. It says,
"Dear pastors, thank you for your
ministry. It is indeed a blessing." The
Bible says, and this is the question.
The Bible says, "Lucifer was cast into
the earth." And he quotes Revelation
12:9 from the King James version. And
the great dragon was cast out that old
serpent called the devil and Satan which
deceiveth the whole world. He was cast
out into the earth and his angels were
cast out with him. I have several
questions in regards to this verse and
this is the first question. Maybe we can
go one by one. Mhm. The first question
is, was Lucifer cast into the earth
before the creation in Genesis 1 and 2
or after creation?
You know, the Bible gives you a general
sequence. I don't know if the writer is
a believer in the spirit of prophecy or
not, but this is one of those times when
the spirit of prophecy gives us much
behind the scenes insight into what is
happening in heaven and on earth. And
one of the things that a reading of the
spirit of prophecy particularly where
I'm talking about the book patriarchs
and prophets uh and also story of
redemption and also uh that original
series called um spirit of prophecy uh
I've read them all. I'm sure you have
also and I know pastor bor who who is
not with us today has also but it gives
you sequence and it gives you a flavor
of what's going on behind the scenes.
So, it makes questions like these uh
rather easy to deal with. Uh you've got
to wrestle with them a little bit more
in the Bible, but you can you certainly
can get the answers from the word of
God, but it's spelled out for you uh by
the pen of Ellen G. White. And uh that's
one of the reasons why I believe that
the spirit of prophecy is such a gift to
the Adventist church to the remnant
church because uh some of these things
which with which with which we may
wrestle are dealt with very neatly and
very fairly easily in the spirit of God.
So was Lucifer cast into the earth
before uh creation or or after? Do you
want to pull out a text or do you want
me to just sort of dive into what I've
got what I've got here? Um you can go
ahead pastor and I can add Okay. Um um
one of the things we find out from the
spirit of prophecy is that the and I'll
use this term the frecus in heaven was
occasioned by among other things the
fact that Lucifer was not included in
the discussion correct uh as they
pertain to the creation of man. He was
not a creator. He was a created being.
Mh. So really uh he had no place there.
But whatever sin was it began with a
jealousy with uh you know there is no
there's no reason there is no no
rationale we can give for sin it's a
it's a existence ele says for whose
existence we can't give any statement
but it had something to do with jealousy
uh and not being included and not given
a place that he thought he deserved to
have. But as a a being who had no
ability to create um you know it's like
if if we're going to build a new
building and the the electricians come
and the and the uh architects come and
I'm sitting mad because I didn't get
invited. Well, I'm not an architect. I'm
not a builder. So what do you need my
council for? You know, I'm not. So why
should I get upset? I can't do any of
that stuff. So I shouldn't be included.
Yes. Uh uh but evidently this soured in
him. So uh this problem existed prior to
creation and uh in indeed uh it was
creation that was the the the the
animous for this problem. So that's one
of the first things it it it existed
before. We also find from spirit of
prophecy that Ellen White tells us that
Adam and Eve were warned that there was
a problem. So um somewhere here it says
it talks about Satan having an
advantage. They were warned that you got
a problem here and um
stay close to each other, stay with each
other, help each other out, do not
wander away and uh you know, you'll be
you'll be fine. Um
we also find out from the spirit of
prophecy that the the the tree of the
knowledge good was a test. Yes. Before
eternal life could be granted. And I'm
I'm I'm purposely going around something
uh because I want to let you jump in
here and I know you're gonna grab it
because you're a smart guy. Um uh
they were they were told something was
going on. They were told to stay
together and um uh my thought is leaving
me. Um they were instructed that there
was a problem in in the universe. Yeah.
Mhm. It's interesting that um we we
don't we don't get uh or we don't sit
together sometimes and and agree to
share the same quotes, but um I had the
same ones that you were just mentioning
about the patriarchs and prophets and
and um God warning Adam and Eve. Very
good pastor. So
yeah, as you said, we cannot see this
specifically from the Bible, although we
can at least infer a few things from the
Bible text. For example, in D in
Revelation 12:es
1- 4, actually through 6,
we see here the devil represented by the
dragon.
And it says here that his tail in verse
well in verse three it says that there
is a great dragon yes having seven heads
and 10 horns and seven crowns or seven
diadems on his heads. He still drew a
third of the stars of heaven and drew
them to the earth. And the dragon stood
before the woman who was ready to give
birth to devour her child as soon as it
was born. Now uh when we studied this
text in depth, we see that um although
it reached its final fulfillment at the
coming of Jesus Christ and when when
Satan tried to uh kill baby Jesus, it
goes even before back to creation when
when the fall because uh from the very
beginning Satan after the promise of
Genesis 3:15 was given Satan Satan tried
to hinder there or to
counteract
uh or to avoid the birth of the coming
Messiah.
So, which tells me that the first four
verses of Revelation 12
refer to Satan's fall before creation,
but verses 7-9
refer to Satan's fall after creation for
a few reasons. For example, um, in verse
9, it says, "The great dragon was cast
out, that old serpent called the devil
and Satan." So, it's referring all
serpent back to Eden who deceives the
whole world. He was cast out to the
earth and his angels were were cast out
with him. Um, that expression who
deceives the whole world, I believe, is
referring specifically to to the to
planet Earth. So therefore when he is
cast out in verse 9 uh he had already
deceived the whole world and that means
that is that is after creation. And how
do we know that this is planet earth?
Because there is then a a a a
woe to those who are in the earth in
verse 12. Therefore rejoice all heavens
and you who dwell in them. Woe to the
inhabitants of the earth and the sea.
For the devil has come down to you
having great wrath because he knows that
he has but a short time. So this must
definitely this happened more
specifically after the cross because we
know that before the cross Satan had
access to heaven even though he had been
cast out. Yes. Uh we see that he still
had access to the heavenly councils as
we see in the book of Job. He could uh
go there as a representative of planet
earth. But here again we see that Satan
is completely cast out of heaven. So I
would say that is both. Uh was Lucifer
cast into the earth before creation or
after creation? I would say is both. The
same applies to was he cast to the earth
before Adam and Eve sinned or or after.
Um ver question number three. It says
the verse says that he was cast into the
earth so that it would seem to imply
that the earth had already been created
for him to be cast into. Uh that that is
his conclusion. And then question number
four, you already alluded to this. Um if
he was cast to the earth before Adam and
Eve sinned, it would seem that this
place Adam and Eve at a disadvantage to
fall into sin since they were now
neighbors with Satan. Um, actually this
is a question. Do you think that God
purposely put Adam and Eve at
disadvantage by casting Satan to the
earth?
No. No. Yes. Exactly. No, I I do not.
Um, God was there. They had counsel.
They knew that something had happened in
heaven and and they were warned. So,
they were not at a dis disadvantage. One
of the things that that I was impressed
in reading the story and harmonizing it
with uh spirit of prophecy council is
Adam and Eve had not known sin. They
were we are born in sin. We are born
with a prediliction to sin. We have we
are sinners by nature by nurture. Um uh
they were not sinners by nature or
nurture because sin had not uh come into
this world yet. Yes. Though though Satan
was here, so they were not at a
disadvantage because sin was something
unknown to them. Had they followed the
counsel of of of their heavenly father,
their creator, and stayed together and
stuck with uh it, they would have uh
been able to withstand. But um they did
not. And it was in in separating that
that uh Satan had access. And of course
things tended to spiral out of control
from from there. Um
yeah. Well, let me stop there. Oh, no.
Do you have something else?
So, yes. Um you you mentioned something
really important uh before that they had
been warned by the angels. Now, some
people might might wonder where does the
Bible say that? Well, the Bible doesn't
say it specifically, but the fact that
Satan took the form of a serpent.
Um, that shows us that he wanted to
conceal his real
uh identity. Very true. So, why would
why would he conceal his real identity?
because he knew that Adam and Eve were
aware of his fall, were aware of his
plans, and that's why he concealed his
identity. And another important detail
here is that when God warned Adam and
Eve to go and eat of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil, uh some
people think that it was because the
fruit had something uh poisonous or sin
was in the fruit, but not in not in
reality. Uh I I believe first of all the
act of disobedience brought sin but also
that u Satan Satan did not have liberty
to go and tempt Adam and Eve all over
the place. It is not that they were put
at disadvantage because they're in this
perfect world and and now God sends them
Satan and Satan's trying to make them
fall. Uh, Ellen White here says in in
Patriarchs and Prophets page 53 that
Satan was not to allow, excuse me, Satan
was not to follow them with continual
temptations. Yes. He could have access
to them only at the forbidden tree. Now,
that's that's an important point. It's a
crucial point in the story. Yes. Uh and
and it bears upon this this idea of
disadvantage. God said, "Don't eat,
don't touch, go don't go near." The only
place they could have direct contact was
at that tree. So they had to go to him,
right? He could not he could not follow
them. So it it it it makes the story a
little bit more intriguing and it's a
very important nuance because she had to
wander over to that tree and entertain
thoughts and questions that he was
suggesting. um had they stayed away they
would have been beyond you know when you
look at it it's it's it's a simple thing
and and and usually the the choice
between right and wrong is not complex
or nuanced or shady or gray it's usually
black or white or white we tend to make
it gray but he cannot chase you cannot
follow you cannot dog your steps you
have to go where he is for him to have
access to you so the first mistake was
knowing where he is. The Bible says,
"Don't make provision for the flesh.
Don't think about it. Don't turn it over
your mind. Don't weigh it. Don't say,
"Well, if I do this, it'll turn out
good. If I do this, it'll turn out bad."
Just say no. And your your safety is in
a determined, you know, there's so much
here. Ellen White says this, and I wish
I had the the quote. She says,
"Indecision actually provokes attacks
from the enemy." Wow. you know, if
you're if you hesitate, if you
vacasillate, well, maybe well, you know,
he that actually aggravates Satan and
makes him come after you more because
you're in in indecisive. Um, she says it
in a context a couple places. One is if
if if you're a young lady and a guy is
beginning to take liberties with you,
you know, you don't say, "Oh, stop." You
know, she says, "Rebuff it." That's
right. with and leave no doubt in his
mind where where you're coming from so
that he doesn't think well if I try a
little harder maybe I'll be successful
no rebuff it hard uh so that there's
there's no hesit well the same way with
the devil when you say no let your no be
no amen you know so Eve went to him he
didn't go to her she plays herself in
the path of temptation precisely yes so
we are running out of time but uh there
is one more question that our other ask
here and this one is in regards to
Ezekiel 28:13. I appreciate your input,
pastor. That was great. That was very
practical. Uh here in Ezekiel 28:13,
it quotes
uh again is referring to Satan and uh
describes his covering. But then there
is specifically a mention that he was
walking in the garden in Eden, the
garden of God. Yes. So the question is,
is this verse referring to the time when
Lucifer tempted Eve to eat of the
forbidden fruit in Genesis 3, or is this
referring to another time when Lucifer
visited Eden before Lucifer sinned and
became Satan?
Neither. Neither. That's just right.
Either you know the answer is is and and
it can be tricky until you read it
several times. Um the context for this
particular verse, series of verses that
surround it is heaven. So the garden of
God is is talking about about heaven
here. The real one. Yeah. He's not he's
not on earth yet. He's got the stones.
He's covered. He wasn't that when he
came down here. Exactly. He was that up
there. So the garden of God is not the
garden of Eden. Mhm. On earth. It's it's
in heaven. Amen. Precisely. I I agree.
The Bible tells us that the true garden
of Eden is in heaven. Revelation 2:7,
for example, we find a promise that uh
if we overcome, we will eat of the tree
of life that is in paradise. Yes. And
then in in Revelation 22:1 again, we see
a reference to the tree of life that we
see it was in the garden of Eden. Yes.
And but here we read that the tree of
life is in heaven. Uh so the real garden
of Eden was in heaven before this world
was created. Yes. Where Satan was
walking up and down with the angels. Uh
Ellen White has a reference and I don't
have time to read it. I'll just u say
the reference. This is Patriarchs and
Prophets page 62. Mhm. Where she says
that the Garden of Eden was um with man
after even after they sinned shortly
until shortly before the flood, but it
was taken out to heaven with uh before
withdrawn exactly before the flood. So
if it was taken back to heaven, uh that
means that u um well the real one is in
heaven. This was a copy of of that one.
Yes. Yes. And and uh just before our
time gets away from us, if you you look
at the the the the nether end of verse
13, every precious stone was your cover.
I think we made this point. Sardis,
topaz, diamonds, barrel, onyx. When
Satan got down here as a fallen angel,
he wasn't He wasn't No, he didn't have
this. Yeah. This is This is uh before
sin in heaven. The workmanship of your
timbers and pipes was prepared for you
on the day you were created. So, this is
very early in the experience. That's
right. Not after he came down.
Well, very good question. We have come
to the to the end of our program. Thank
you so much. See you next time.
[Music]